in Hollywood it usually takes a little
while for a new box office record
breaker to emerge but it does happen
eventually
right now Avengers endgame holds the
crown but for how long
here's a look at some of the upcoming
movies that might just be able to cut
shorts and games all-time rain it's
pretty much a certainty that Star Wars
the rights of Skywalker will be one of
the year's biggest releases while Star
Wars is one of the highest grossing
franchises in American history only a
new hope ever reach the top spot to
become the highest grossing movie
worldwide a lot has happened since 1977
with international grosses playing a
much bigger role in a film's performance
and while Star Wars certainly is a
ubiquitous as ever the two most recent
films in the series didn't quite attend
game levels at either the domestic or
international box office the spin-off
solo a Star Wars story underwhelmed
financially while 2017 the last Jedi
made six hundred and twenty million
dollars domestically and the 1.3 billion
dollars worldwide which is pretty damned
impressive to be sure but it's still
less than his predecessor the force
awakens and far less than endgame
throughout the nine film 3 trilogy
Skywalker saga a pattern has tended to
emerge in which the second film and each
trilogy dips domestically before the
final installment dominates the box
office however to top the numbers
worldwide you need a strong
international showing and Star Wars
foreign totals typically just aren't as
great as EMC use for example while the
force awakens is the highest grossing
domestic release ever it's only fourth
worldwide so while the rise of Skywalker
may very well top Avengers endgame at a
domestic box-office it looks like a long
shot to set the worldwide record the
Jurassic Park franchise has always been
a stoic showing at the box office so
what a drastic world threes chances of
topping endgame when it opens in June
2021 well Jurassic Park was the highest
grossing film ever worldwide until
Titanic took the top spot and while the
later installments in the first trilogy
open to more tepid reactions Jurassic
wells set a record for opening weekend
and enjoyed a stunning final grossed of
six hundred and fifty two million
dollars domestic and almost 1.7 billion
dollars worldwide life finds away its
sequel Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
didn't do quite as well however well
there was probably fair to say Universal
isn't crying about as 1.3 billion dollar
global take all in all the Jurassic
franchise seems to be following in all -
Thurman
a pattern audiences flocked to the first
one but once the novelty has worn off
the grossest gets smaller and smaller
don't expect to see the Jurassic series
go extinct anytime soon but don't expect
it to gobble up Earth's Mightiest Heroes
either Avengers 5 doesn't have a title a
storyline or even a release date heck
it's not even part of Marvel's phase 4
as far as anyone knows and yet it's one
of the most anticipated movies in the
near future if for no other reason than
it follows a record smashing Avengers
endgame whatever form Avengers 5 takes a
few things are certain namely that some
events games biggest stars will be
nowhere in sight so don't expect Robert
Downey jr. Chris Evans Scarlett
Johansson or Josh Brolin to show up the
real question is then whether Avengers 5
will have the same draw without these
cornerstone characters of course it's
possible
Black Panther Captain Marvel and
spider-man have each made Bank of the
box office and you know the studio will
pull no punches and making Avengers 5
just as big an event as as predecessor
but whether it's enough and whether
Marvel's lightning can strike twice well
that remains to be seen of course it's
entirely possible that it won't take
every avenger to top endgames gross
maybe it'll only take one black panther
thanks to its insane 700 million dollar
domestic gross black panther is the
highest grossing solo superhero movie
with a taken of 1.3 billion dollars
worldwide that's bigger than anything
puts held by any other superhero ever
clearly black panther scratched a niche
so what does that mean for a sequel with
the notable exceptions of Iron Man 2 and
Avengers age of Ultron just about every
MCU sequel has made more than the
previous film both domestically and
worldwide that means the sky seems to be
the limit for the king of Wakanda sphere
adventures but the question is it's just
how high can he go complex answers
historic grows be battered with a sequel
or was a record-breaking gross a black
panther the consequence of a perfect
storm of culture and cross-promotion
colliding much like Avengers 5 the title
storyline and complete cast for the
sequel are still unknown and all anyone
knows is that it's due for release on
May 6 2022 but what we do know is that's
what Black Panthers domestic take was
historic its overseas grosses were a
little lower than other Marvel movies -
really L do endgame black panther 2 is
going after opus international game
considerably if any single superhero can
take down Earth's Mightiest Heroes it's
gotta be Batman arguably the most
popular costumed vigilante on the big
screen Batman's
buying domestic gross as 2.4 billion
dollars if we adjust that for inflation
even most Batman movies came out more
than 10 years ago its 3.5 billion
dollars this is also the only franchise
to break the opening weekend record four
times although no Batman movie has been
the highest-grossing film ever
domestically or worldwide the biggest
hit in the franchise The Dark Knight
made five hundred and thirty three
million dollars domestically placing it
second behind Titanic in North America
the Dark Knight's worldwide take however
barely makes the top 50 at just over 1
billion dollars ever since the Dark
Knight Rises
Batman has kind of been in a dry spell
but the Batman hopes to change that when
it opens on June 25th 2021 the movies
connection to the DC EU is unclear but
it promises to be a complete reboot for
the character and the last reboot in the
series Batman Begins performs well
setting the stage for the record
breaking Dark Knight and sure there's
been a little fun backlash after Robert
Pattinson is casting in the title role
the fans protested Michael Keaton's
casting too shows all they know
Indiana Jones 5 scheduled for July 9th
2021 release is shrouded in more secrecy
than the Ark of the Covenant itself but
what can we expect from its box office
performance Indiana Jones total domestic
crows is just over nine hundred and six
million dollars and while that might
seem unimpressive adjusted for inflation
that comes to two point 1 billion
dollars domestically across just four
films which is pretty incredible still
it's hard to gauge how Indy will do in a
new environment driven by international
grosses Indiana Jones on the Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull made three hundred and
seventeen million dollars stateside and
seven hundred and eighty six million
dollars worldwide in 2008 not great but
not bad although as we saw with star
wars the force awakens historic run fans
really really liked seeing Harrison Ford
playing as most iconic characters
it's the ranch and well India's never
been quite at the level of lucasfilm's
golden goose on the galaxy far far away
it's still a franchise that enjoys a
rock-solid place in pop culture history
in d5 might not be a frontrunner for
becoming the highest-grossing movie of
all time but it might just become the
highest grossing indie film worldwide
and could well make enough money for
Disney to fill up a whole Temple of Doom
the Skywalker saga isn't the only Star
Wars relatedly deities Thea slated for
release over the next few years far from
it currently Game of Thrones showrunners
David Benioff and DB Weiss are working
on a Star Wars trilogy while the last
Jedi director Rian Johnson is working on
his own - on top of that Marvel had
honcho Kevin Feige is developing a film
for the studio all-in-all the studio has
Star Wars films booked through the next
decade trading holiday release states
with avatar sequels in a bid to dominate
the universe 1 December at a time it's
doubtful that Disney needs or even cares
if any of these films break away to
become the biggest of all time sure they
wouldn't complain if any of them did but
that's not exactly the goal the real
goal however is to replicate the MC use
multi franchise formula and while that
sounds good in theory
solo prove that you can't make Bank just
by slapping the Star Wars name on it
still with a slew of talent behind these
upcoming movies plus the influence of
the man who made Marvel what it is today
Lucasfilm could find themselves raking
in the credits very very soon James
Cameron has been teasing the expansion
of his avatar franchise for so long that
most fans have gone Navi blue in the
face by now cameras have finally started
rolling on no fewer than four avatar
sequels and a total cost of one billion
dollars that may seem like a crazy
investment on a franchise that'll be 12
years old by the time the next one
arrives in 2021 but this is avatar after
all until july 2019 it was the highest
grossing film ever worldwide and it
remains the highest grossing overseas
pair could the first avatar sequel could
bomb and the franchise would still be
one of the biggest ever based on the
first film's performance alone but
that's unlikely to happen the past
decade has seen many pundits predicting
Cameron's Avatar sequels will fail
mostly stemming from the fact that
avatar doesn't have the same hold on pop
culture as say Star Wars or Lord of the
Rings and that may be so but once that
first trailer hits finally showcasing
whatever CG and juice fever dream
Cameron has cooked up you can bet your
bottom dollar that fans will be
ordering the tickets in their droves but
hey why start from scratch who Satan
avatars see call us at top Avengers
endgame when avatar already had a head
start less than ten million dollars
separates avatar in dead game
so if avatar were to be released to
build anticipation for its sequels
there's a solid chance that would take
its record back be releasing films is
nothing new there hasn't been as common
a thing since the arrival of home
entertainment and on-demand streaming
services but what's a little friendly
competition when a world record is at
stake the only problem is since Disney
purchased Fox Disney would be
responsible for the reissue meaning
there be competing with themselves
Disney obviously wanted endgame to take
the record hence the decision to
re-release the movie a few months after
release with just a few minutes of extra
footage now that they've done it well
they turn around and have avatar usurp
it money matters but pride counts too
now that Disney owns Fox expect avatar
to stay right where it is firmly behind
Avengers endgame nobody would have
predicted James Cameron's movie about
the sinking of a big boat will become
the highest-grossing movie ever even
fewer predicted that Cameron would top
his own record with an original sci-fi
film about Space Marines fighting
12-foot blue aliens yes everybody knew
endgame was going to own the box office
but nobody predicted that see less
superhero Ironman would spawn history's
most successful franchise either so who
knows what could happen in the future
despite that endless data and analytics
that go into every Hollywood movie which
movies hit big and which films flop hard
really is anyone's guess Hollywood is
knee-deep in the IP era but as summer
2019 has proven lots of moviegoers are
suffering from sequel itis may be the
future highest-grossing film won't be a
franchise entry at all but an original
work or maybe it'll be based on a
popular book or maybe like Titanic Gone
with the Wind and save many huge
box-office hits before it'll be some
kind of epic historical romance
maybe the biggest hits won't even come
from America with a gross of more than
700 million dollars 2019 seventh
highest-grossing movie worldwide is a
Chinese film the wondering earth could a
foreign film become a breakout hit in
the US as with all things only time will
tell
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]